[Musik]
die positive stimmung ist teilweise sehr
kritisch gegenüber dem auto geworden
es gibt nach einem unfall kam
forderungen auf nach einer obergrenze
stb wie stehen sie dazu
wie sehen sie diese debatte um das auto
gerade in deutschland
wenn sie das thema sed ansprechen das
ist ein sehr spezifisches thema und da
muss man dann eben auch schauen welche
kunden sich svs kaufen international und
erste wie sehr beliebt in nordamerika
und in china wo es viel raum gibt diese
fahrzeuge zu fahren da wirken die
deutschen es manchmal schon sehr klein
gegenüber den fahrzeugen die dann dort
auf dem markt sind und ich halte sehr
wenig von von regulierung
jeder kunde muss am ende entscheiden
welches produkt für für ihn richtig ist
ich selbst bin auch jemand der in der
innenstadt nicht so gern mit dem sv
veert wenn die räume eng sind wenn man
den engen parkhäusern unterwegs ist aber
gern wenn ich über land fahre mit dem
scb und habe weiter sehr komfortabel ist
insofern kann man diese diskussion nicht
pauschalisieren
man muss das ganz spezifisch sehen und
dann immer auch auf den kundennutzen und
am ende jeder kundenwunsch immer vor
gegenüber jeder regulierung
[Musik]
klimaschutz ist zunächst dass mal ein
absolut globales thema weil wir alle
gemeinsam auf dieser welt leben und da
ist der anspruch dass mein anspruch dass
jeder verantwortung dafür übernimmt dass
wir auch in zukunft eine welt haben die
die lebenswert ist
das wird natürlich nicht in allen
regionen der welt so gesehen oder auch
in dieser intensität diskutiert ich
finde es viel wichtiger wenn wir uns das
jetzt in deutschland ansehen
aus diesen diskussionen konkrete
maßnahmen abzuleiten und diese dann auch
umzusetzen
es bringt wenig wenn wir wenn wir nur
diskutieren und in zehn jahren da nichts
erreicht haben sondern fokussieren sich
die richtigen schwerpunkte anschauen
mit einer genauen analyse wo habe ich
die größten hebel dahinter dann
programme setzen wie ich dann der
verantwortung gerecht werden die
diskussion unter das auto
international wird häufig nicht
verstanden weil man deutschland als das
hightech-land die automobilindustrie
sieht und
ich bewege mich viel im ausland durch
durch unsere porsche aktivitäten und da
sind die leute begegnet dem mit
unverständnis dass sie sagen manche
macht eure eigene industrie kaputt das
ist das was deutschland stark gemacht
hat und da wird das einfach nicht
verstanden welche diskussionen hier
möchte ich mit porsche in eine neue ära
das fahrzeug stellt innovativ die
speerspitze der elektromobilität da ist
sportlicher emotionaler als andere
fahrzeuge die heute auf dem markt
bekannt sind technologisch mit einem 800
volt netz was es ermöglicht deutlich
schneller zu laden
als das bisher möglich war von der
fahrdynamik beschleunigung von 0 auf 100
in 2,8 sekunden mit der porsche typische
fahrdynamik mit lenkbaren hinterachse
drei kammern luftfederung und vielen
features die man vom porsche gewohnt ist
also ein porsche zu 100 prozent
[Musik]
die forscher werden natürlich mit dem
porsche im boxermotor und den verbrenner
in verbindung bringen wie überzeugen sie
die gerade bei der elektromobilität war
es uns wichtig von beginn an dieses auto
so aufzusetzen
das ist ein porsche durch und durch ist
vom design über die qualität und über
alle fahreigenschaften das heißt wenn
ein porsche kunde bei porsche elektrisch
fährt dann wird er keine abstriche
machen wird das fahrzeug zu 100 prozent
als branche auch wieder erkennen
wir haben mit dem fahrzeug eine
reichweite im wtb das ist der der neue
zyklus von 450 kilometern haben dann für
uns auch noch mal ein belastungstest
inklusive laden gemacht wir sind 24
stunden gefahren auf unserer teststrecke
in nardo in italien haben dort über 3400
kilometer inklusive laden hingelegt und
das zeigt einfach wie alltagstauglich
das fahrzeug ist lade kilometer auch im
winter 450 km hängt natürlich auch von
den temperaturen ab
wenn man jetzt temperaturen von minus 20
grad hat dann ist es weniger aber durch
die ganzen tests die wir gemacht haben
sehen wir eben das war dort in einem
bereich der für kunden auch absolut
komfortabel ist
wir erwarten zunächst erst mal dass 80
prozent unserer kunden das fahrzeug
daheim laden
das ist erstmal komfortabel aber gerade
auch für lange strecken muss natürlich
die alte infrastruktur stehen wir haben
selbst ein joint-venture editiert unity
was in europa eine schnelle
infrastruktur aufbaut
wir werden dort im nächsten jahr 400
stationen überregional haben so dass man
alle 100 km eine station hat an die man
dann intelligent vom fahrzeug
angesteuert wird
wir haben aber im grossen schon dort
noch einiges vor uns auch gemeinsam mit
der bundesregierung wenn man das jetzt
auf deutschland bezieht den
energieversorgern und anderen investoren
ladeinfrastruktur nach und nach
auszubauen dass es in den verschiedenen
ländern der welt sehr unterschiedlich im
moment und wird aber in den nächsten
vier bis fünf jahren rasant zunehmen und
hat dann natürlich auch einen
wesentlichen einfluss darauf wie
elektromobilität von den kunden an
die top version bringt 280.000 euro an
der turbo bei 150000 wir werden dann
aber im laufe der nächsten monate dann
auch fahrzeuge anbieten die in
niedrigere preissegmente gehen und der
teig an einsteiger wird so bei 95.000
euro liegen
das sind menschen die umweltbewusst
leben die auch ein statement setzen
wollen die technologieaktien sind
ich glaube da bieten wir mit dem tag
herr die komplette bandbreite auch ein
ganz neues segment für porsche zu
erschließen so eine typische tesla
konnte bisher hat jetzt alternativen
sich tesla war jetzt nicht die
unbedingte orientierung als wir dieses
fahrzeug aufgesetzt haben wir haben uns
immer selbst als maßstab genommen und
haben gesagt wenn wir ein
elektrofahrzeug bringen musste sich
fahren wir einen neuen elfer dass das
macht er das kann ich bestätigen weil
ich das fahrzeug auch schon viel
getestet habe aber jetzt sind sicherlich
auch kunden dabei die in der
vergangenheit in trister gefahren sind
jetzt sagen ich mag die porsche der
marke porsche und das fahrzeug was
porsche mit dem teig kann dort auf die
straße stellt besonders innovativ ist
und sich einfach noch mal sportlich auch
die emotionalen wert
[Musik]